Netflix is adding a bunch of awesome content
in July 2019 and getting rid of a lot of great
titles too.
Here are our picks for the movies you have
to stream one more time before they leave
the service.
In the mood for something swinging, shagadelic,
and downright groovy?
Netflix subscribers have until July 1st to
catch Mike Myers as the buck-toothed, babe-obsessed
British spy Austin Powers in the first two
films of his action-comedy franchise.
Austin Powers: International Man of Mystery
centers on its titular spy as he wakes up
in 1997 after spending 30 years on ice following
an assassination attempt by Dr. Evil.
Also played by Mike Myers, Dr. Evil soon concocts
a plan to hold a $100 billion ransom over
the world.
"$100 billion!"
What comes next is a string of silly antics,
evil henchmen, beautiful "fembots," a Generation
X son with serious daddy issues, a doomsday
device, and plenty of James Bond gags.
Meanwhile, The Spy Who Shagged Me, takes everything
fans loved about the first film, then adds
a clone, a time-traveling VW Beetle, a Scottish
Guard, and a volcano lair into the mix.
If laughter is what you're after, an Austin
Powers double feature is just the thing for
you.
The dark fantasy drama from Academy Award-winning
director Guillermo del Toro, Pan's Labyrinth
made it onto countless best-of-year lists
when it opened to sweeping acclaim in 2006.
In the 13 years since its release, the film
has been regarded as one of the greatest movies
of all time and the best of del Toro's illustrious
career.
Set in Spain in the summer of 1944, the film
follows Ofelia, a young girl who discovers
that she may be the living reincarnation of
a royal whose father ruled the underworld.
One evening, Ofelia follows an insect she
believes to be a fairy into a labyrinth where
she meets the Faun, a being who tasks her
with three missions she must complete in order
to become immortal and live in the underworld
as a Princess.
Pan's Labyrinth leaves Netflix at the end
of June so enter the maze and discover its
magic before it's too late.
If you have yet to see director Jonathan Demme's
psychological horror film, July 1st is your
last chance to do so on Netflix.
The Silence of the Lambs, an adaptation of
Thomas Harris' 1988 novel of the same name,
follows ambitious young FBI trainee Clarice
Starling as she builds a relationship with
imprisoned cannibal serial killer Dr. Hannibal
Lecter.
She needs his advice to catch another insane
serial killer, "Buffalo Bill."
Within the cold walls of the Baltimore State
Hospital for the Criminally Insane, Clarice
offers personal information to Hannibal in
exchange for clues on the identity of Buffalo
Bill and how she might apprehend him.
One of the top-grossing movies of 1991, the
winner of multiple Academy Awards, a critical
and commercial success, and a film preserved
in the National Film Registry, The Silence
of the Lambs is a cinema classic and a linchpin
of the thriller genre.
Don't miss watching it from the comfort of
your couch while you still can.
There's no telling what Dr. Lecter might do
otherwise.
A census taker once tried to test me.
I ate his liver beans with some fava beans
and a nice glass of chianti."
If you're suffering from a serious case of
Keanu Reeves Fever, you'll want to watch The
Matrix trilogy before Netflix clears the films
from its content library.
First, dig into 1999's The Matrix, featuring
Reeves as computer programmer Thomas Anderson,
who hides a double life as a hacker named
"Neo."
When he meets Morpheus, Neo's reality is forever
changed after he discovers that the reality
he knows is completely fabricated.
Neo realizes that he's been trapped in the
Matrix, a system that presents a false reality
to its victims and feeds off their minds and
bodies.
Once your brain has been thoroughly blown
by The Matrix, dive deeper into the stylish
world with The Matrix Reloaded and The Matrix
Revolutions.
James Cameron's 1984 sci-fi flick The Terminator
is essential viewing for anyone who loves
cyborg assassins, Arnold Schwarzenegger, high-stakes
time-travel, and bombastic action sequences.
It's also a required watch leading up to the
premiere of November's Terminator: Dark Fate.
As if you don't already know, the film features
Schwarzenegger as an android sent from the
year 2029 to 1984 Los Angeles to kill Sarah
Connor.
She'll eventually become the mother to the
man destined to save humankind from a sentient
artificial intelligence system known as Skynet.
Meanwhile, a human soldier from the future,
Kyle Reese, risks everything to protect Sarah
from being terminated.
Whether you're reliving the action or witnessing
it for the first time, catching The Terminator
on Netflix before it leaves in July should
be at the top of your to-do list.
Because it's going:
"Hasta la vista, baby."
Vince Vaughn and Owen Wilson star in Wedding
Crashers as best buds and partners in crime
who have perfected the art of crashing weddings
and wooing women.
In a hilarious montage, the film quickly chronicles
the pair's most successful wedding season
ever, then brings the audience up to speed
on their riskiest mission yet: sneaking into
the wedding of a daughter of the U.S. Secretary
of the Treasury.
Featuring more one-liners than we can quote
here and an absolutely hysterical performance
by Will Ferrell, Wedding Crashers is the epitome
of R-rated, mid-2000s comedies.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the best
movies on Netflix are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.